well it had to happen eventually the
frustration from being
unable to send out his screeds and
diatribes via twitter was going to get
to former president donald trump
and there's a report from the daily
beast
that trump is so frustrated from being
unable to send out insults on twitter
because he's banned
uh that he's been writing down insults
and giving them to aids and asking them
to tweet the messages out this is being
reported
uh by the daily beast um sources close
to trump
said to the daily beast that uh trump
was really really upset
i'm so wound up about the story i just
threw my sharpie
the entire liz cheney thing where there
was a referendum within the republican
party about liz cheney and whether she
should
retain her leadership role or not and
uh you might recall that liz cheney was
one of the 10 republicans in the house
that
back in january voted to impeach
donald trump in the house of
representatives now leading to his
upcoming
second impeachment trial and this entire
time
trump couldn't tweet he was desperate to
tweet he was desperate to attack his
political
opponents and what is being reported is
that trump has quote
written out insults and observations
several of them about liz cheney i
assume summer about her physical
appearance
because it's trump uh and has resorted
to suggesting
put-downs for others to use or post to
their
own twitter accounts and
uh i mean this is you know it's it's so
ridiculous and childish but completely
obvious
that you know i was thinking trump trump
almost seems more upset about not being
able to tweet
than he is about not being president
anymore and then i thought well
he might actually believe he still is
the rightful president
because he believes it was supposedly
stolen by joe biden
trump seems to know he's definitely
banned from twitter
i have this image of trump sitting at
mar-a-lago
or wherever he is i don't even know with
construction paper
and crayons but not the thin crayons the
fat ones where like it's impossible to
write anything coherently
sitting there writing out insults with
one of the fat crayons and a piece of
construction paper and seeing who might
be willing to tweet it out
i think we'll know if trump's written uh
screeds are getting out on twitter
like if we see stephen miller tweet that
little marco rubio
isn't really a patriot or something
about ted cruz's wife's physical
appearance
we'll know that it's probably not really
stephen miller tweeting it's probably
actually donald trump
and as we observed during the presidency
this is a man trump who seems to have
like a bottomless reflex or a desire
to just insult people it comes so
naturally to him and a lot of it
from what we know seems to come from
from his childhood and the way he was
raised and
the relationship with his dad not to get
all all freudian
um and uh it's it's really the type of
pathetic behavior that just reminds us
again that this guy never had the
temperament to be president of the
united states
and we think back to hillary clinton
during the debates in 2016 who said this
man is temperamentally unfit to be
president
and of course she was completely right
um and
uh for the last uh what was it
few weeks i guess month or so of trump
being on twitter more than more than
half certainly i don't know what
percentage
of his tweets were being labeled either
misleading
or were restricted by twitter for either
spreading conspiracy theories or
making false claims about elections or
whatever the case may be
and now we are seeing a real rift in the
republican party
where you have lawmakers who want to
completely get rid of even trump almost
like
a race trump from history and get rid of
his influence
and then you have this other side the
marjorie taylor green
lauren bobert side that seems determined
to
keep trumpism going to trump to some
degree
and that's what led to this movement
within the republican party to try to
remove
congresswoman liz cheney an anti-trump
or at least a trump skeptical republican
from a position of power
it failed it failed and throughout all
of this donald trump
uh reportedly very pleased with marjorie
taylor greene
desperate to get somebody to tweet out
the insults that he's been coming up
with so
i i don't know what else to tell you but
trump behaving exactly as we would
expect him to behave let's face it most
healthy snacks
don't taste that good they don't fill
you up they don't really satisfy your
cravings
which is why you should check out monk
pack today's sponsor
monk pack keto nut and seed bars taste
like your favorite delicious sweet
snacks but each bar
has less than one gram of sugar only two
to three grams of net carbs and they're
just 150 calories these are perfect
for a keto or low carb diet or
anybody who wants to cut back on sugar
flavors include caramel sea salt sea
salt dark chocolate
and peanut butter dark chocolate that's
my go-to i love
the monk pack keto nut and seed bars
because they're just a good balance of
sweet and salty
soft and chewy and a great crunch from
the nuts and seeds
and they will give you all of your money
back if you don't love them as much as i
do
go to monkpack.com the link is down
below and they'll give you
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman